Bitches.
Well we've tried,
we've tried other online interventions
too,
so I have my these youtube videos up,
but we also designed.
I work with some corporations awhile
while back because I've done some
consulting and I had designed tests to
help people hire better employees,
which I still do and in fact I work with
this company up in California called the
founder institute and it's the world's
largest stage early technology company
incubator.
It's created 2,500
companies in the last four years and we
test now in 135 cities,
but when I was marketing these tests to
companies,
they kept asking me what could be done
about their poorer performing employees
and I said,
well,
I didn't know because it's not that easy
to.
If you have someone who's problematic,
who's troubled,
it's not that easy for a manager to
figure out how to straighten them out
and they just don't have the time.
They don't have the time.
They don't have the manpower and they
don't have the training usually to do
that.
But I designed to set of programs called
the self authoring suite and one of
them.
The future authoring program helps
people write out a plan for their life,
so it helps them to ask you some
questions about six dimensions of your
life.
You know your,
your health,
mental and physical,
your use of drugs and alcohol,
your wishes three to five years down the
road for intimate relationships,
for family,
for career,
for education,
and so on.
It asks you,
what could your life be like three to
five years down the road?
If you set it up for you like you were
someone you were taking care of,
so it asks you those six questions that
it asks you to write for 15 minutes
about about your vision for your life.
You get to have what you want and what
would be good for you.
What would that be?
And then it asks you to write for 15
minutes about what your life would be
like three to five years down the road.
If you let your bad habits and your
idiocies in your foolishness is in your
weaknesses,
take the upper hand in,
Auger you into the ground because
everyone knows about that.
And so it's like you get to design the
little heaven to strive for and little
hell to avoid.
And then you write for.
Then you basically turned that into an
implementable plan.
That's the second part of the program.
We've used that with about 5,005
to 7,000
university students now mostly in Europe
at the Rotterdam School of management.
And we've raised their grade point
average of their kids.
Twenty five percent drop their dropout
rate the same and it's had a walloping
effect on men and on non Western ethnic
minorities,
it's moved the nonwestern ethnic
minority student population performance
at Rotterdam,
School of Management from 70 percent
below the,
the average to above the female Dutch,
uh,
natives.
And so the other reason I'm telling you
this,
apart from the fact that it's a very
good program.
And um,
we,
we did it at Mohawk college in Canada a
year ago and we dropped their dropout
rate in the first semester,
50 percent,
and that especially again worked well
for men because men are at more risk of
dropping out now and,
and especially for men who didn't have
good grades in high school.
So not only is there the possibility for
the net to provide tremendous
dissemination of intellectual material,
but there's also the possibility for the
net to provide dissemination of
psychological interventions that have
major impacts on people's mental health
and productivity at almost at
extraordinarily low cost.
So that's really been fun too.
So why think providing some that sort of
a structure and a framework,
giving people the tools just inform of
asking them questions.
What would you like to do is describe
this,
what is your view?
And when you do that,
you sort of allow them to help
themselves outline what they would like
to accomplish,
which most people don't do.
Well,
in our education system,
our education system was designed in
Chicago in the late 18 hundreds to
produce factory workers because it was
set up when when rural people were
migrating to the cities on mass because
their kids,
first of all,
we're likely to get factory jobs and
second of all,
if you were working in factory,
your kids needed to be taken care of and
so the purpose of the schools was to
train factory workers,
which is why everyone's lined up in
rows,
rows and why there are bells.
It's a factory model.
The problem with that is that now
people's careers basically have to be
self determined,
but that's never.
That's never part of the education
system.
Part of the reason I developed these
programs was because I realized this is
the same course where I'm teaching
students that if they would have been in
Germany in the 19 thirties,
they would have been Nazis.
I'm trying to get them to design their
lives and it's way better to have
someone articulate their own plan.
You actually neurologically rewire
people by having them formulate their
own thoughts,
which is why you know,
your school teachers used to say,
put it in your own words.
It's actually very good advice.
If they would explain what that means.
It's like if you have to conjure up the
thoughts and you have to articulate
them,
then they change you.
And so.
Well,
and so this program has had the,
the,
the effects have been absolutely
overwhelming for us as researchers
because it's very,
very difficult to produce an
intervention that actually has a
positive effect on people,
you know,
you hope it does,
but generally when you test it out,
it's like,
no,
it doesn't do what you thought it did.
Or sometimes it even has the reverse
effect.
That sounds fascinating.
Now,
how do people have,
how can someone,
a regular person have access to this?
It's called self authoring.
So that's s e l,
f authoring,
like,
like writing a book,
self authoring Dotcom and the programs I
gave away the future authoring program,
I think it might still be free.
Um,
it was,
yeah,
it is until the end of November.
I did a video called message to
millennials were because one of the
things Jonathan Heit said about,
uh,
he called Karl Marx,
the patron saint of the social justice
warriors and John Stuart Mill,
that patron saint of people say who
stood for objective truth and freedom of
expression.
And I thought that was really smart.
He said Brown university is number one
for social justice universities in
Chicago for truth universities.
But one of the things that marks has
over John Stuart mill is that mark's is
a social revolutionary and young people
like to think about ways to change the
world.
Right?
And that's actually a positive part of
their development.
It's a stage that the developmental
psychologist,
Sean Piaget called the messianic stage
and he associated that with late
adolescence.
So like,
while young people want to change the
world,
the problem is,
is that that's been harnessed into
attempts to change other people,
but that isn't what you should do if you
want to change the world,
you should change yourself.
And I don't mean that in some cliched
sense.
I mean it in the sense that Alexander
Solzhenitsyn said when he analyzed the
Soviet Union,
he said,
don't be thinking that the line that
divides good from evil runs down
political spectrum or,
or,
or countries or something like that.
It runs down right down the middle of
your soul and if you want to sort out
the world and what you do is you sort
yourself out.
It's a serious business,
right?
They say it's more difficult to rule
yourself than to rule a city and that's
the truth because you're a complicated
and there are horrible monsters inside
of you that needed to be tamed and to,
and to be brought in,
to be brought into alignment and
submission so that you can be a powerful
and useful person.
And I gave away the future authoring
program as part of this video.
I made suggesting to millennials that
instead of rushing out there to change
the world by changing other bad people,
that they should look inward and sort
themselves out properly.
And,
um,
I think we've given away about four or
5,000
of those programs so far.
It's about free till the end of November
and then what happens with it?
Well,
the self or the future authoring program
is regularly $14 and ninety five cents
and the whole self authoring suite which
involves.
It's a program that helps you write an
autobiography so it helps you sort out
things about your past that are still
burdening you.
You can tell a if,
if you have a memory that's more than 18
months old approximately,
and when you pull that memory up to
mind,
if you still have an emotional reaction,
that means you haven't fully articulated
the memory,
you haven't analyzed it causally,
you haven't.
You haven't freed yourself from its
grasp and you're carrying it like a
weight and your brain responds to that
like the more have more weight you're
carrying like that more baggage.
Let's say the more of the stress Hormone
Cortisol your brain produces and
cortisol makes you old.
Some of the work has been done by James
Pennebaker at the University of Texas at
Austin because he.
He started to pioneer these sorts of
writing programs and he found that if
people wrote about uncertain things,
past,
present or future so they could be
traumatic things,
they could be uncertain,
things that their physical health
improved and he.
He did a lot of detailed research trying
to figure out why that was and basically
came down to the explanation that it was
something like an uncertainty reduction
mechanism at work.
Because your brain is always figuring
out how well situated are you in the
world.
How much do you not know to how much
have you mastered?
And you can tell that you've mastered
things.
Because when you go somewhere and you
act things turn out the way you want
them.
That's an indication of mastery and your
brain is sort of keeping track across
your whole life of how many places
you've been,
where things haven't worked out compared
to how many places you have been,
where they have worked out.
And if all those places in your past
where things haven't worked out,
you need to map and master and that.
That decreases the existential load on
you.
But that actually decreases your
psychophysiological load,
it makes you healthier,
it makes you less stress,
and so we've put all that together in
this self authoring suite to help people
write about their past,
to sort it out in a,
in a detailed autobiography,
it asks you questions about your past,
it says,
divide your life up into six epochs and
then divide each of those that might be,
say,
oh,
birth to kindergarten and then maybe
elementary school and then maybe junior
high school however you want to do it.
And then to write about the emotionally
significant events in each of those
epochs and then to describe their
effects on you and then to analyze how
you did in those situations,
what you might have done differently,
what you might do differently in the
future to straighten out your past.
And I've done that with my students in
my maps of meaning class for about the
last 10 years.
And some people have written 15,000
words.
It's not that uncommon for students to
write 15,000
words and their autobiography.
Wow.
So that's such great advice.
That's such great advice about
reconciling with your past.
Because so many people just carry it
around.
Yeah,
well,
if you're.
If you're thinking about your past,
what it means is you haven't analyzed
the causal chains because you might say,
well,
why do you remember your past?
While you might say,
well,
it's in order to have an objective
record of the past.
It's like it has nothing to do with
that.
There's only one reason you remember the
past and that's to be prepared for the
future.
That's why you remember the past,
and so what you're supposed to do is
take the past and extract out from it.
Wisdom and wisdom is the ability to
avoid stumbling blindly into ditches,
and so you think,
well,
here's a time in my past,
I stumbled blindly into this horrible
ditch and terrible things happened to
me.
It's like,
okay,
you need to take that apart.
You need to figure out how was it that
that events conspired with your
participation voluntarily or
involuntarily so that that terrible
consequences emerged.
You need to know why that happened and
how you could react differently in that
situation.
And as soon as you do that,
your brain will leave it alone.
You won't obsess you about it anymore
because the anxiety producing parts of
your brain are basically trying to tell
you where there are obstacles in your
environment.
It's like,
look out.
Don't go there.
It's like,
well,
don't go there.
There's fire.
Well,
maybe you could master the fire,
right?
Then you're a wielder of fire.
You're not just a victim,
and lots of situations are dangerous or
not dangerous,
depending on your level of mastery,
right?
Life is like that.
And so a negative emotion that's
associated with a memory is something
that's crying out for mastery and
writing can really help with that.
So you're reorganizing your brain.
When you write autobiographically,
you're,
you're basically the emotions.
Imagine emotion memories can be stored
at different levels of your brain,
some sort of primordial reptilian image
laden areas that are very emotional opt
to finally articulated plans for your
future life.
Will you want to take everything that's
negative and emotional and transform
that into a fully articulated vision for
your future.
And that frees you of your past.
You shouldn't be thinking about your
past.
I mean maybe if you're 80 and you know
you're going over a well spent life,
that's a whole different thing,
but if you're 30,
35 or 20,
and most of the time you're thinking
about your past,
it's like it's like your soul is trapped
back there and you need to.
You need to free it through
investigation and the metaphysical
language is appropriate because that is
in a sense what you're doing.
You're trapped in the past.
It's like you've got to break free of
that so you can use all your resources
to move ahead into the future.